good evening everyone
um my name is ian i'm aware that i'm the
last speaker of this evening
and so i will try to give you a lot of
information
and then we can move on to whatever food
or beers or whatever else
you have planned so i'm going to be
talking here
on making pandas fly so who am i i'm an
interim
chief data scientist this means i run my
own company and i go and work with a
variety of companies
uh on their different data science uh
problems either helping teams or solving
intellectual property problems so
writing code doing data science building
machine learning models that kind of
thing i've been doing this for nearly
two
decades now it's nearly 20 years i've
done lots of things in lots of different
organizations
um i'm also co-author for
high performance python which i'm super
excited about one of the reasons i'm
excited
is normally when i've when i've got the
book i'll be at a conference i get to
sign it the uh the conference i get to
talk to people about it and that's
brilliant
having written this and got it published
just a month ago we're all in lockdown
so i can't physically give anyone a copy
so you are the
the first audience i think that i'm
showing a physical copy to so this is a
book um
all about making python code mainly
numeric code
go faster great for data science work of
course
and my co-author is misha gorelick i'm
also one of the co-founders of
pi data uh pi data london uh
the the london branch uh i'm super proud
of the community we built there with
over 11 000
members um and i look forward to
hopefully seeing some of you either at
international party data events or
events back in london uh when we pass
lockdown
i also teach courses on things like high
performance because it turns out i'm a
little bit uh
i get a little i care about this i
really get enthusiastic about it
and i'll mention some more of the
courses uh later on
uh before we proceed but the talk uh i
wish to remind you all
uh that all the volunteers in the pi
data world are volunteers
uh so i would invite you all as
attendees who are enjoying a very fine
conference
uh to remember that your volunteers your
organizers and your speakers are all
here volunteering their time
so go into uh discuss go into the lobby
channel
and say thank you uh it's a nice thing
to do um
and uh the the money raised behind the
conference goes to num focus that's the
non-profit that benefits all of us in
our
python data science and wider python
ecosystem
so it's a great uh charity behind all of
this so go and say thank you
so what are we doing today we're going
to talk about pandas mainly focusing on
pandas i've given variants of this talk
looking at different parts of the wider
pandas data science ecosystem
today's talk is focused on pandas we're
going to save ram we're going to see how
that can impact some of our speed
and we're going to look at some other
ways of calculating faster including
going behind the scenes
of numpy and then i'm going to reflect
uh at the end
on uh some advice uh some of which is in
the book and
there's more that i've been thinking
about on being generally more performant
in our data science
roles so are we going to start with uh
a demo so let's go to my oops
let's go to the right notebook here we
go so this is my
making panda
loading in some data i'm loading in um
the uk companies house basic company
data
data set so this is a live data set
updated every month
um we get about four and a half million
records coming through
in a csv file reasonably well
um four and a half million rows and it's
all of the extants all of the existing
live companies uh that exist uh in the
uk
um and you can see here some of the
fields that we're going to be looking at
company name an accounts day um
category uh an incorporation date so a
variety of
different data types the d types that we
see in pandas dtype being a data type
and often inherited most of these are
inherited from
numpy numpy being the numeric python
library
that sits behind many of the
pandas columns so we load in this data
set we do a little bit of
formatting uh telling it how to deal
with some of the daytime parsing
and then i ask it uh for df info so
dataframe give me your information
uh and it tells me what my d types are
what my columns are
and then down here it tells me the
memory usage
and that's a lie that number's wrong for
a start uh it's wrong for a good reason
it says 203
megabytes or 203 plus megabytes uh so
it's telling us that it's at least
200 bytes but probably more and it turns
out that by default uh the info command
doesn't check the string
objects uh so that's all the uh the
objects that we can see there the
company name the registered address
and the company category it doesn't
introspect each of those because each of
those strings has a different size
associated with them
it's a bit memory intensive to calculate
we'll look at what the uh
the true size is a bit further on so
here's a first little tip for you when
you're doing info
you can actually ask it to calculate the
memory usage you can say memory usage
equals deep
and then it will go and calculate the
memory usage of all of
all of the items in all of the columns
including strings and we'll find out
here that
it's much larger it's a good gigabyte uh
i think it's a gigabyte or so
what can we start to do with this data
well
one thing i'm interested in is what kind
of companies do we have uh in our data
sets
uh in a the wider context i've been
using this data set to look at the
effect of the
pandemic on company registrations and
dissolutions that's closures of
companies in the uk
and if we have time i've got a bonus
slide which uh i might show on that
so here we can do a value counts in
pandas so i take the company category
and i ask for a value counts and i ask
it to give me the top 10.
there's about 30 or so different company
types many of them have very small
counts there's a bunch of just
really interesting nuances around some
of those companies but they occur very
infrequently
the most common company type here is a
private limited company
that's 4.2 million occurrences so it's a
limited company it's
the same kind of limited entity we see
in lots of countries
here i'm going to ask for the company
categories
memory usage with that deep equals true
flag turned on here you can there's a
couple of different options here
that we can use deep equals true that's
the slow complicated one
i actually ran it seconds before i came
onto this call slightly hard in mouse
because i was
uh running a bit of code live uh which
was very silly of course
um because i've changed the format of
this i wanted to print out the bytes
that we see here you can see that
this string column four and a half
million rows costs about
820 megabytes that's a huge amount of
storage
uh it's nearly a gigabyte just for this
one column separate to all of the other
columns that's a lot of ram that gets
sunk into this
so how can we save some ram here well
this is uh
this is so well i guess one question
would be why
we have more ram for other data so
either more columns of data
or for more rows of data one of the
problems with pandas
is that uh in its basic state
it can eat a lot of ram for some column
types like strings but also just for
floats and integers that we'll see
shortly and so you end up limited by the
amount that you can put into ram and
pandas doesn't have a memory mapping
back to disk option everything has to be
in ram
so if we can compress our ram so if our
data types eat less ram we can get more
rows into ram or more columns depending
on what we're looking at
and this means we can do more just with
our basic pandas without having to learn
a new system like desk or modem or fakes
or one of the other alternatives
so how do we compress well uh one of the
obvious ways of compressing
any data that is frequently repeated uh
in the last year or so is to use the new
category data type so we can say
uh df company category that's our column
as type
category and then we get the category
version back it's a very quick
operation and then i do value counts on
my company category underscore cat this
is my variant column that i've set up
and i look at those counts and i've got
the same count so i get it
460 megabytes rather than 820
it's nearly half the size for almost no
work at all so that's brilliant that's
really nice
and now it turns out as long as we're
not manipulating these strings if we're
just using them as some kind of
indicator
then uh a lot of our operations will
have twice as much memory available to
them so that's brilliant
is it the case that it might go faster
well there's a good question i'm glad
you asked that
so let's look at behind the scenes uh
how is our category set up well we've
got the categories
back there turns out a lot of instances
of
very few strings so this is brilliant
for this compression
inside categories and it's set up using
this categories list
and codes and then the numeric codes are
the thing that's actually stored that we
operate across
if we start timing some operations so
i'm using percent
time it here on the data frame on
company category to do a value counts
that operation costs 400 milliseconds
the same operation applied to company
category underscore cat that's the as
type
category variant takes 23 milliseconds
so it's a huge saving that's uh what's
that that's 10 that's 20 times
faster so that's amazing now your
mileage will vary depending on
the kind of data sets that you're using
if you can't compress that much if
you've got
lots of strings then of course you won't
get that much memory saving
you should still get some memory saving
if you've got any kind of repetition in
your data
it only doesn't work when you don't have
any repetition in your data
and it works really well for strings and
it can work for numbers as well as say
if you're using
integers as some kind of ordinal
indicator so you have a large number of
a few
different unique numbers um then it
might be the case that the categories
give you some
some improvements there as well and of
course
the operations run a lot faster now what
else can we do with this well
if i take my data frame and i set index
to company category that's the original
string column
and i make one new data frame a df2 no
cat
and i take a second data frame df2 cat
where i've set the index to be the
category variant and then i time
some lookups using a mask on the index
then it turns out we have another huge
saving 288 milliseconds compared to
uh 400 micro seconds so at
orders of magnitude faster that's that's
an amazing speed up
so if you're doing certain kinds of
look-ups on your data
and you've got lots of strings and you
haven't come across categories before
i certainly recommend that you try to
try to use the categories here
this came up in my high performance my
higher performance python class that i
ran
recently and one of the attendees on the
course was really looking for ways to
speed up some of their indexing
uh we discussed the category option i
didn't know how well it would work out
on their data set
it turns out that solved the one
bottleneck that they came on the course
to try to get around
and solve the whole pile of issues so it
was a really nice discovery and it
really got me thinking more about how i
can use categories
uh in my own code
so let's try a different column uh and
uh think about our data in a slightly
different way
uh so uh let's make a numeric
column so here i want to know uh how old
my
companies are and then i want to do a
couple of calculations off of that
i don't have that column i've got i've
got a date time so i'm just going to
make a delta
column so i'm going to take the date
time now
and then the incorporation date of each
of my companies
create a delta go into the dt
accessor that's up here if you're new to
pandas if you've got a date time column
you can do
dt to get some date time operations like
the number of days that are represented
behind that date divided by 360 and i
get an approximate number of years for
the age of the company
i do a little sanity check here just to
make sure that i've got no negatives
coming through
it turns out the way the data is laid
out if i use the default pandas date
time processor
my months and days get inverted back to
front and once they're inverted then
i might have sometimes i get day day
month month sometimes i get month months
day day and so my dates get flipped back
to front
and it turns out some of my badly
interpreted dates are in the future and
then i get negative ages in this
calculation that of course is bad news
uh so i need to go and fix that and i
put in this a search check and i'm going
to reflect upon this kind of checking
inside notebooks just to validate some
basic assumptions and do some data
quality checks
uh a bit later on in the talk uh so
i'm just going to graph this just so
that we can see it here we can look at
the distribution
of ages in years of each of the
companies
it's not a terribly informative chart it
tells us that the vast majority of our
companies
very young and then some companies that
are 20 years old
there are a few more companies that are
40 years old and the company ages go up
to
over 100 years actually so we do have a
few very old companies in the uk
i don't really care about that this uh
for the the purposes of this talk
i just needed a a new numeric column
uh so let's uh do a quick describe on
that column
uh i've got four point four million uh
rows of
years i've got mean age well with that
kind of skewed distribution i don't
really care about i mean that makes no
sense
um but i've got my minimum my maximum my
interquartile range and i can see those
numbers there
uh to many decimal places way more
precision than i actually need i've got
a 64-bit
uh floating point number a float 64
behind this column
that's the default in pandas so that
takes eight bytes so it's
uh that's eight bytes that's a lot of
bytes uh times
four million rows um that's a lot of
precision when i just want an
approximate age could i do any better
could i save some ram well of course i
can
um i can uh call as type and ask for a
float
32 so using four bytes rather than eight
bytes and i'm going to call this age
[Music]
is my numbers are the same so it turns
out with eight bytes or with four bytes
i get the same result
well that's kind of brilliant because
this means that i could just cut my ram
usage in half
and then i could fit more more data into
ram
and possibly just possibly because my
data types are smaller
possibly when i do operations the data
flows faster
so maybe i can get some speed ups and
we'll see that in a little while
the more important thing to me is that i
can just compress my ram usage i'm not
doing any actual compression
i'm simply using fewer bits to store the
same information
there will be some imprecision that's
introduced as a result with these long
floating point numbers here they're
rounded on screen
but to 20 30 decimal places there will
be some impression in that
conversion down where i lose half the
bytes but for my approximate age i don't
care
many times in the world we end up with
in 64s and float 64s
counting very small or a small
range of numbers sort of a small number
of very interesting numbers
and ignoring the rest of the bits that
could be representing very large or very
tiny numbers
and then we forget about that and we use
more ram than we need to
so we can do some uh conversions and
then things will go
then we'll get more data into ram so
let's uh
let's just do another double check here
and see what happens if we use the float
64 the float 32 and the float 16.
uh so if i iterate through
float 64 then the float32 version and i
look at the range of my
company ages i can see 0.0472
up to 190 same precision for float 64
and float 32
at least to several decimal places which
is way more than i need for this
particular problem
but the ram usage is halved 35 meg down
to 17 megabytes so that's brilliant
so it's a really nice save this is a
good thing
um but if i use a float 16 i do halve my
ram usage again
but now i see that the imprecision is
beginning to creep in
and this is not looking quite so good um
but you know for my approximate needs
this is actually fine
um but depending on your needs this
might be this might give you too few
bits of precision so maybe you get some
rounding there's an important note in
here and we'll see this on a chart later
float 16 is hardware simulated so it's
slower than float 32 and float 64.
so let's just have a quick recap if i
use my original data set
company category as strings and ages as
float 64s
that's about 800 megabytes using info
memory usage deep
and if i do the same thing with the
category version and the
32-bit uh version of my age
then i'm down to 450 megabytes nearly a
50 savings that's pretty significant for
verily
work now wouldn't it be nice if there
was a tool that could tell us how we
could compress our ram well i was
thinking this just recently
i didn't mean to put it in the book i
didn't get around to writing it so i
wrote it
a month or so ago and it's a super
simple tool it iterates through the
columns in your data frame here i'm
taking a
sample of a one million rows on a subset
of the columns just to keep this easy
and then i ask my dtype diet tool to
report on data frame and it tells me for
example the company name column which is
an object where every company name is
unique
it has no suggestions for that it turns
out it doesn't know how to compress
something that's unique
however the company category which is
frequently repeated
it says it takes 89 megabytes in this
particular sample
and we could save 80 megabytes by doing
company category
as type category that's a really nice
saving just as a simple suggestion
and we get the same thing here for the
float service float 64 down to float 16
for an account ref day
and although i noted that there might be
a speed hit around that
it's worth noting if you look at the
read me on this project there's a bunch
more advice in there i've got a couple
of other people trying it and beginning
to bring ideas to this you'll only find
it on my github it's not been released
anywhere yet uh if this is interesting
to you
don't have a look at my github and give
me some feedback i'd love to hear what
you think
i'm just going to zip through this bit
uh there are a couple of ways of doing
our queries in fact
in pandas there are lots of ways of
doing the same
uh age five in this case query is a very
powerful operation
it's powerful therefore it's a bit
slower it can do things like taking
variables from the local namespace and
do some very complex evaluations
uh it takes in this case uh nearly 500
milliseconds for an operation
if i generate a boolean mask of the same
query so dfag is less than five and use
that as a mask to dereference the rows
that i want
it takes about half the time so that's
really nice
um masking is the the bread and butter
way to look things up in pandas but if
you read lots of the guys they talk
about using a query because it's pen
because it's powerful it's great that
it's powerful but maybe it's a bit
slower than you need
and then we're going to drop in here and
then go back to the slides uh
final thing to think about many of our
columns are represented in pandas by
underlying numpy
data types uh like a float 64 or the n64
we can do our operations on those
underlying data types by calling say the
column ages dot sum
and it takes a while to get our result
back but if i do ages
values to go down to the float 64 that's
behind this
and ask for a sum well it happens about
10 times quicker that's kind of crazy
that's a huge speed up right
10 times speed up just by going down to
the underlying
numpy column numpy array uh behind this
pandas
series by putting the dot values
accessor in there
and i'm going to return to the slides
talk about that a bit more because it
turns out
i'm almost doing the same job here and
i'm slightly misrepresenting this
as i learned in the last week so back to
the uh
back to the slide first of all thanks to
james powell he was speaking this
morning
um he gave me a bit of code a couple of
months ago because i was starting to ask
the question well what's happening in
pandas behind the scenes when i call an
operation like series.some
james wrote a bit of code recently which
just tags every time you go into a
function and you run a line of code and
then it calls another function which
calls a line of code
uh it tags it all and then builds up a
nice cool graph so i get an idea
as to the fact that behind a series sum
there were 25 files being touched and 83
functions being accessed
that's quite a lot just for a summation
and if we look into that
we zoom in just a little bit here we see
things like the indexes being touched
the underlying nd array uh is it an
extension type
um and a bunch of d type querying going
on there's a bunch of work going on
behind the scenes
and this is because pandas is very
powerful has to do a lot of checking
if you go to series.values to go to the
underlying numpy array and then call
some
18 files and 50 functions and if i page
back so that's the more complex
going via pandas to do it and this is
the uh simpler way of doing it if we go
directly via
directly by numpy so it's faster and
simpler on code and that's why it's a
bit faster
but you do have to know what you're
doing if you're going to go in that way
if it turns out you don't have a numpy
right behind the scenes you can't call
dot values that would make no sense you
have an optimization
if you know that you can go behind the
scenes so this led me to ask the
question just recently like in the last
week
um is it the case that uh it's always
faster to come out of pandas and go
into uh go into numpy to do an operation
so i've been experimenting i've had some
other collaborators on this which is
lovely
and i've learned a lot out of this so in
this chart we've got two bars blue and
orange blue is going to the panda series
for an operation like
mean and orange is going to the panda
series getting
values and then from dot values calling
the operation like
dot mean um it turns out so on the left
most chart
in 64 that takes 800 megabytes for this
uh
10 million row random vector
inside pandas blue and orange they're
about the same size that means the
operation takes about the same time
in each of these uh pairs of columns the
orange is at least
slightly faster than the blue slightly
lower 0.01 seconds
but mine are a tiny bit of jitter but
generally a little bit faster
if i take an n32 variant so then as type
in 32 on the underlying data it takes
half the ram brilliant
but hey look at that speed chart it
actually gets a bit faster so it gets
faster in pandas and it's faster if you
go directly
to numpy behind the scenes we don't get
any more speed ups if we go into 60
and intake we just use less ram but then
it gets crazy if we get a float 64.
the pandas column the blue column that's
nearly 0.06
whereas the orange column series dot
values going to numpy is 0.01
faster than the int equivalent that's
kind of crazy and i thought now this
this has got to be wrong with my machine
it's my hardware it's something
so i had a few other people replicate
this and hey indeed it turns out
this general behavior persisted um
however oh yes that's right
uh so however uh by filing the bug and
the bug is listed at the bottom there it
says
so uh it turns out i was missing the
bottleneck library so here's a tip for
you if you do the standard pandas
install
you don't get the bottleneck library by
default here i've installed it
and then i've used the pandas options
compute use bottleneck to turn it off
i then call series.mean and i get 54
milliseconds
i turn bottleneck back on serious domain
i get 16 milliseconds that's a
three-time speed up
for installing a library that i can get
for free off the internet that's
brilliant that's a great speed up
if i go serious.values.mean so via numpy
it's five milliseconds it's still
three times faster again what's going on
well as i learned that if
you go and read this bug report you'll
see the discussion with some of the
pandas core maintainers and thank you
very much to them for educating me
it turns out the pandas mean is not the
numpy mean
pandas mean is actually doing a nan mean
so a
nan missing number respecting mean
whereas because i know that my data has
no nands in it i didn't bother with the
nan meaning numpy
i just called the mean function which is
faster because it's not doing any nand
checks
so it turns out i wasn't quite comparing
apples and oranges in this case
but if you know the uh what's in your
data you know that you've got known ends
you can always go back to numpy and make
things run a bit faster
so here are some some opportunities for
you to get your
code to be highly performant
i've mentioned the bottleneck library
there's also numexpre that's another
library that makes queries and eval
in pandas go faster both of these are
referenced on the
pandas documentation for enhancing
performance
so if you search for pandas enhancing
performance you'll get this page
there's loads of good advice in there
including how to use number
and syphon to compile your code but some
of the tips are hey there are these
optional dependencies
which if you install them make your code
run faster for free
so i would strongly suggest you don't do
that uh i've mentioned that my dtype
diet is up on my github page
so i would dearly love your feedback on
that please go and have a look at that
and if you're doing any operations that
consume lots of ram and you're wondering
what's going
on in the background you might be
interested in my ipython memory
usage that tracks between every call in
an ipython or jupiter session
how much ram is used in the background
which might be released by the time you
come back with the answer
to get an idea of a ram envelope running
behind operations
that can help you slim down your code
and i think this actually might be the
more important slide here
i think reflecting on 20 years in my
career
that the thing that makes me slow is not
that my code runs slow
it's that i make mistakes and that's it
i think the biggest thing is i make
mistakes
i miss think i mistype but really i just
get stuff wrong and then things go wrong
so pandas helps us out in various ways
there's an
int 64 that's available now with a big
eye not the lowercase
i this is not in pandas this is not in
numpy
the big-i version the big-i version is
only in
pandas that gives you nullable integers
rather than forcing you to use floats
there's an equivalent for boolean and
soon there'll be one for float 64 with a
big f
so it's all inside pandas which gives
the pandas devs an opportunity to give
us more speedups
use that your code will be saner write
tests unit tests end-to-end tests
uh i live and die by the test that i
write it means that i trust my code
if you're not checking your assumptions
and you saw in that notebook i used some
assert statements
that's a really cheap bit of a nasty way
of checking some assumptions but it's
better than having no assumption
checking even better
use a library design for this like the
bull walk library bulwark i super
recommend you go and have a look at
bulwark
and then put some of those tests around
your pandas data frame
and i've realized that i make notes for
things i'm learning in various different
places
i've decided to codify some of these for
me in a public easily accessible place
so i've got a notes to self
repo up on my eons fold github repo uh
they're not notes for you they're notes
for me but they're public so hey you
might be able to get some value out of
them every time i do something
twice now that i know i've looked up in
the past a bunch of matplotlib stuff and
type checking stuff and panda stuff i'm
putting it in there so that it saves me
time looking up and misremembering
things
maybe these things these ideas help you
to become a bit more performant in your
work
so in summary uh make it right then make
it fast
uh think about being more performant as
a developer in your process think about
actually where you
lose your time it's probably not in your
query not running fast enough
it's probably in your general work
practice so have a think about that
a lot of this stuff i talk about in my
classes uh they'll be up on my blog soon
i've got one on um
higher performance python lots of
compilation and profiling and the like
one on software engineering for data
scientists where i focus more on unit
testing and refactoring to make good
code
and another one on successful data
projects so all about the bigger picture
of data science projects
how to make them work from beginning to
end from design through to delivery
uh and i think that's pretty much all i
need to say right now
my final point is if you've learned
something here
i would love to hear about that and i'd
love to hear about it by way of a
postcard people send me postcards they
go onto my noticeboard and they're a
physical reminder they're almost like
customer feedback they're a physical
reminder
that i've done something useful with my
volunteer time so if you'd like to send
me a postcard send me an email i'll send
you my address i would love to receive a
postcard from anywhere around in the
world
thank you very much